is nevada governor steve sisilak
honoring former eight news now anchor
paulie gonzalez as part of women's
history month in a tweet yesterday he
recognized her time spent mentoring
young hispanic students interested in
careers in journalism as you may
remember paulie was an award-winning
journalist here at channel 8 and the
first latina evening news anchor in
nevada she died in a car accident the
day after easter in 2005 leaving behind
two daughters who survived the crash
that's sabrina and gabriella
i just talked to sabrina last night we
are very much in touch and very close to
the girls
and i i just have a hard time believing
that that was 2005.
um it seems like paulie was right here
on the set yesterday
and uh the time passes really way too
fast although the girls were much
younger and they're growing up now what
are they 20 something they're in their
20s they just turned 25 and 22
and graduating from college wow but
leaving a beautiful legacy and then
having the governor recognize her and
all of her hard work yeah and she's
remembered quite often here in las vegas
and i'm so glad and there's probably not
a week that goes by that somebody
doesn't ask me
about the girls or mention polly's name
and comes up you know sometimes out of
the blue but it's really a wonderful
thing that she's not forgotten and nice
that the governor recognized that online
as well